ever wonder what your favorite disney
villains good side would look like
we're not just talking about their best
angles these are
full character glow-ups baddies no more
we're transforming these disney villains
to see what they would look like if they
were less wicked
chic new hair perfect skin flawless
makeup
and keeping a little of their sass with
badass new outfits
these villains are getting a major
makeover with glow-ups like these
let's hope the baddies don't look back
my dear sweet child
that's what i do
[Music]
[Applause]
so
you are not leaving this tower
[Music]
ever
[Music]
so
[Music]
well that event i'd best be on my way
[Music]
[Music]
oh well in that case i'll take them all
the whole litter
just name your prize dear
[Music]
[Music]
bring back her heart in this
[Music]
who's been painting my roses red
[Music]
the fates are here and you didn't tell
[Music]
me
[Music]
it is no concern of mind whether your
family has
what was it again
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
you may even have thought it was love
but the slipper fits
[Music]
i'm just full of surprises
[Music]
you see we left the present
[Music]
do
these villains are definitely ready to
find their happily ever afters while
serving these amazing looks
let us know your faves in the comment
section hit that like button and
subscribe to the things for more
incredible transformations
thanks for watching